alors là de la dernière question la
question que nous avait tous se poser
c'est nabila va-t-elle revenir à la télé
alors ça chez le chien j'aimerais bien
vous répondre bien sûr mais seront on ne
peut pas parce qu'en fait on doit
attendre l'issue bien sûr judiciaire de
cette affaire pour pouvoir y répondre
parce que même dire nabila va revenir
pourrait influencer l'enquète voilà je
vous le dis donc on peut pas dire on ne
sait pas si nabila va revenir à la télé
on va attendre la fin de l'enquêté on va
attendre la fin de l'histoire je me
demande si elle étonne innocenté est-ce
que vous la reprendriez dans l'émission
si elle est innocente et écoutez je
pense je pense que oui ça je pense
qu'elle aura qu'une envie quand elle l'a
si elle sort parce qu'on ne sait
toujours pas ce qui s'est passé au ces
pommes et si jamais voilà je pense
qu'elles auront vie et je lui
conseillerais vivement d'aller se mettre
un peu au vert oui on lèche est retombé
le souffreteux revenir tout de suite
exacte est on verra quelle qu'elle soit
je prenais vie je pense aussi julien
courbet maintenant en conclusion de
cette affaire on peut dire c'est vrai
comment on pense aussi bien sûr à thomas
à composer c'est moi mais vous rendez
compte quand même ça c'est quand même un
drame il a vécu heureusement on l'a dit
voilà son état de santé etc s'est
améliorée il va mieux et des sorties
d'hôpital mais c'était quand même la
femme qu'il aimait donc c'est vrai que
volatile dans sa tête ça doit pas être
facile
aujourd'hui on pense à nabila on espère
voilà que cette enquête va aboutir très
très vite et sachez que nous voilà on
est on est juste triste parce que on
voit là c'est quelqu'un de l'équipe on
est toujours triste quand il arrive
quelque chose si le regarde on leur dit
aux deux courage pour la suite et voilà
pense avoir mes deux motos rien car très
exact et on les lâche pas denis thomas
qu'on connaît moins bien ni nabila voilà
merci à vous d'avoir un chien tueur
section c'était pas évident